Film Courage: In our 2017 interview Cory we touched
on the movie Battlefield Earth so maybe
we can talk about it again and that is I
believe you're one of the co writers on
the movie?
Can you explain what happened and also
help explain to other screenwriters
maybe what could possibly happen to them?
Corey Mandell, Screenwriter/Instructuro: Sure
thanks for bringing that up. Film Courage: Oh sure...yeah
I'm here to open all those old wounds.
Corey: Yeah so let me I'll walk you through
sort of what happened and how it
happened but then I it with your
permission I want to back up and sort of
talk about a more important aspect to it
so what happened is I I felt like I was
so unlucky
out of the gate well no I felt
incredibly fortunate I sold this pitch
really sick I was gonna make it he
almost made it but then there was just
all this crazy stuff with German
investment studio politics just all the
stuff that nothing to do with me or the
script it didn't get me to Prague two
projects later of a director of a
greenlit movie studio greenlit movie
director in Africa scouting locations
and then the head of studio lost his job
the new person came in and shut down all
of the projects that the previous person
had greenlit so that now it was dead and
I could go on I had five projects in the
first five years that were greenlit but
didn't get made and so I just thought
god hates me and I'm the unluckiest
person in the world and then I met more
and more writers who had the exact same
stories and I realized oh it's not that
God hates me
God hates writers and it's just this is
just the nature of the beast
now I so I had a so I'm sorry so what
happened is the last time I had a I'd
written script that almost got made but
the star backed out and it's just so
clear you need a star to get it over the
finish line so I got a call from agent
saying that they want to meet you at MGM
John Travolta was a huge star at the
time
and for bath so I want you to go take
the meeting do not say yes to do not
take the project but meet John Travolta
and his producing partner these are good
relationships and you're going to meet
the head of the studio head of MGM so I
went in and took the meeting and they
told me what I wanted to hear and I
wanted to hear it and they told me this
has nothing to do with Scientology you
know we had a science we had a writer
from Scientology and the script is
completely unusable we're not following
the book literally in fact John's gonna
play the main character and the main
character in the book is like a young
like 17 year old or 18 year old and you
know John's middle-aged man at this
point and we spent a big Star Wars movie
and it's gonna be really fun and and
just told me everything I'm on here and
John Travolta was like it was really
good that make me feel really special
and it's gonna be a great movie and all
of this and I was very respectful but I
I said no but I was really tempted
because I'm like this will get made and
this could be a big fun Star Wars movie
maybe and it has Travolta he's very
motivated to do this but I said no it
was really hard because at the point I
was feeling like if I don't get
something made no one's gonna hire me
again because you can write some scripts
that get close to being made and they
don't get me but at some point if you've
written five six seven scripts that
haven't actually got made then at some
point people are gonna blame you and I
really felt like I was and I went in
there I was getting there so then it
leaves MGM and it goes to Fox 2000 they
pick it up and Laura Ziskin is running
Fox 2000 and she came she was when the
first industry people ever met cuz I was
in film school and she came to speak to
us and I was mesmerized she's so
intelligent and she's just so amazing
and just feels it's just so much ethics
and has was involved in some of my
favorite movies
so they once again made a run at me and
I have dinner and I said yes and Fox mm
you know they were very clear like this
has got nothing to do with Scientology
and it's gonna be this kind of a movie
and all of it
I felt very
secure in saying yes now I want to be
clear
my wife said don't say yes my agent said
don't say yes my friend said don't say
yes my Golden Retriever Toby said don't
say yes in his own golden retriever way
so so everyone else was saying don't do
it but I did it and I'm gonna come back
to why I said yes the real reason I said
yes I'm gonna come back to that but I
said yes and I got paid a lot of money
and I wrote this correct and two or
three days before I turn the script in
Fox 2000 was out there was a change with
Laura I mean Fox 2000 was out and the
project got picked up by franchise films
which isn't a real film company there
are a financing company since gotten a
lot of trouble but so when I turned the
script in there was no studio there were
no executives it was just John and his
producing partner and as far as I can
tell spiritual advisors came in to fill
that void because there's no real record
of what the development was at that
point because it was no longer a studio
movie and so there were changes to the
script that I was not involved in and
then the movie got made and and it had a
miniscule budget for the special effects
and it was terrible and I don't mean to
be offensive thing was a Scientologist
but in the industry that was not seen as
a positive in fact I went on I could
round of meetings for a year after that
movie where people just brought me in to
see how did this happen and are you a
Scientologist everyone wanted to know if
I was a Scientologist which I am NOT and
so yeah so basically the once you turn a
script in you don't own that script you
have no control over the changes if it's
a studio film there's going to be a
record of the developmental changes
there was no record nobody well some
people know I have no idea who I've
heard rumors but I have no idea who
rewrote it and why but they rewrote it
back to the book and then John for some
reason decided instead of playing the
seventeen-year-old character he was
gonna play the space alien he was gonna
play like this giant space alien which I
don't think was probably the best choice
so anyway the movie was just a complete
unmitigated disaster
I remember I was in Vegas when it came
out I was so depressed cuz I was like
that's it my writing career is over
I was actually secretly a little
relieved but I was mostly depressed I
remember talking to my agent who like
talked me off the ledge and he's like
people in this industry know what
happened and they are not gonna hold
this against you and your career is not
over it's gonna be a little more
challenging but your career is not over
if this ever happens again your career
is over that you can survive this one
and again just I think I was just so
blessed and fortunate I continued to
work as a writer at my full quote with
heads of Studios major directors for
four more years like it should have
ended my career I was fortunate that I
had a track record of writing scripts
that had attracted major elements that
almost got made didn't get made so I had
that
so people were willing to say okay this
was an unmitigated disaster we're not
gonna hold this one against you and and
I got to keep working I think if I was a
newer writer without that track record
it would have been over for me but I
want to I want to sort of back up
because all of that kind of does it kind
of it kind of divorces me of a lot of
the responsibilities of sort of like
okay I knew I shouldn't say yes but I
said yes and then right for her in the
script in the studio backed out and it
was franchise films and and all that's
true but I want to back up after the
really Scott deal happened an agent
Barbara Dreyfus was an agent the time
just she wasn't my agent but she was
such a good person that she took me out
to lunch if that wasn't her client and
she said Cory the script that you wrote
to get your career and the script you
wrote from a droplets that really is
going to make now is not the most
important script of your career the most
important script of your career is the
next script that you write because now
you're on the radar now people know who
you are
this next script will seal your fate
this next script will put you on a
trajectory what career do you most want
and that's what the script needs to be
people are gonna offer you a lot of
money to write scripts that you don't
want to write you have to say no you
will be scared that the offers will will
slow down and they may not come you have
to take that risk
the offers won't slow down worst case
everyone offers a script everyone offers
your project to write and you don't want
to write it you say no to everything and
worst case they stop offering you things
write a spec you have to write the
script that you most want to write that
is authentic you have to write the
script that you're going to that is
going to be a 10 on a scale and the
tents got to be exceptional because this
next script is going to seal your fade
down the road if you want to take a
project just for because you're getting
paid obscene amount of money you can do
that down the road not right now and it
was one of those times when when she
said that I Scott this chill up my spine
I'm like this is true I was offered a
project I didn't want to write I said no
it was offered another project I said no
the studio came back and offered me more
money I said no they came back and
offered me a lot more money I thought
about it I said oh I'll write the script
I absolutely do not want to write the
script
I said no he's really hard then they
said we want to meet with you at least
so I went to meet to get the
relationship and in the room they
offered me more money and they talked it
all up and they played in my ego and I
said yes so there I was like I failed
this test really early on and like from
that moment on I was just I was always
reacting I didn't have a center I was
just reacting I was scared I just wanted
more I just wanted I didn't want the
deals to end and I just kept taking
deals that in my soul I knew I shouldn't
be taking but I did and if you do that
over time it's going to lead to
Battlefield Earth if you just keep
reacting and you don't find your
integrity in your Center and you just
give your power to the industry and do
whatever it takes to keep getting work
it's going to end terrible
I feel like I completely deserve
Battlefield Earth it was the I was just
making reactive fear-based decisions and
that's what it leads you to and I was
able to talk myself into taking that
project yes I didn't know Fox 2000 would
drop out I had no idea about fan choice
films there was a lot I couldn't foresee
but I knew in my heart that I should say
no and I said yes so I own that and I
deserve that
I can now look back at it and say it was
it was literally one of the greatest
things that have ever happened in my
life because I was so afraid of
rejection I was so afraid of what other
people thought this movie came out and
like you could imagine looking through
the LA Times or the New York Times at
the reviews I mean they were brutal I
mean this this movie is a punchline
to jokes today I mean this is considered
one of the worst movies of all time and
I am one of the credited writers and
even though most people don't understand
how the industry works and what that
really means I am one of the credited
writers I'm one of the worst movies of
all time I you for me like there was no
greater sense of rejection or shame it
was it was beyond what I was most afraid
of didn't kill me I came out of it
stronger I came out of it humbled I came
out of it for the first time starting to
hear that voice inside me I started to
pay attention to who I was I started to
realize and then when my father died I
realized life doesn't last forever and I
realized that I'd been living my life
based making all these fear-based
decisions and not saying Who am I and
what matters to me and why am I on this
planet and those questions and that led
me ultimately after 40 I worked for four
years after breaking I wish I was
breaking bad Battlefield Earth I worked
for four years after that and then I
walked away and just
to be clear I don't want to make it look
like I was at the height of my career
and I walked away the offers were
getting harder and harder they were
slowing up it was getting harder and
harder to book a job I felt like I could
squeeze another one out but I walked
away because I didn't want to write I
didn't want to do this anymore and the
one thing that I've loved in life is
teaching and I was teaching at UCLA like
once a year for for the fun of it when I
was writing and I remember talking to my
wife and I'm like if I could just teach
like I feel like that's my purpose and
she's like then that's what you're gonna
do and I was thinking I can't make that
fear voice was still like I can't make
any money doing that and she's like do
it you you you just spent 10 years doing
something for the money and you were
miserable I mean ah I waited like 40
pounds more than this I had treated
myself and other people badly has so
much pain so much rage jeez you deserve
you know we got money in the bank for
now
you deserve to to pursue just what you
love just try it
so I did and and I am so proud of I have
six teachers now teaching under me I'm
so proud of what we built over the last
seven years I'm so proud of everyone has
gone through our program who's not
working and selling stuff and I would
never be the teacher I was today if it
wasn't for Battlefield Earth I'll just
talk about process and creative
integration and it all came from that
pain that I own that it was my fault
that it happened yeah I said yes what I
knew I shouldn't and it is the best
thing that ever happened to me
you know from that moment on it's like
when I when I want to make an instinct
or I have to make a decision in my my
instinct is to do this but I have this
fear voice of what what would people
think or you could be rejected it's like
well it ain't gonna be a bad as battle
filler you know and I survived that so
yeah it really softened me and it really
made me like really pay attention to
like my instincts and my impulses and
that that's allowed me to be the teacher
that I am so I think everything happens
for a reason
and I think that I was put on this or
to teach and Bala fell earth was a big
part of that and it's it was a big part
of my training to be the teacher that I
am and I remember when I first started
teaching like well no one's gonna take a
class for me like who's gonna say hmm
let's take a writing class from the guy
who wrote one of the worst movies ever
it I can't explain it but ever since I
started like my classes are sold out we
we have waiting lists as I said I have
six teachers that teach under me I don't
know why but but I think people it's all
referral-based and I think people
realize that what we're teaching no one
else is teaching we're really teaching
people how to change your relationship
with writing how to change your process
and how to become an even better writer
than you knew you could be we're not
teaching paradigms and rules we're
actually teaching people how to be
writers so sorry if I overreacted but
and there's anything else that you're
curious about in terms of bath or thumb
I'm happy to answer it don't you think
it's it's almost better to have someone
who's gone through so many ups and downs
teach something rather than somebody
who's either flatlined or yeah it's been
just nothing but successes well how
somebody get up always because most
people's careers are never just a
straight line it's not yes I agree and I
mean so first of all I feel so and just
the danger of over answering it I think
what I do uniquely as a teacher is that
I can help writers recognize their
process either you're in charge of your
process or your process is in charge of
you and for so many creative people
they're not fully aware and responsible
for their process they're not in charge
of their process and I'm really good and
working with writers to figure out like
where their pain and fears and and where
they have an unhealthy relationship and
where it's sabotaging them and what they
can do to get to heal that and to evolve
their process to become a much better
writer and part of it is the whole time
I was writing I was obsessed with
process I talked to every successful
writer every unsuccessful writer but
particularly success writers and I
wanted to know what's your process
what's your process because I was I
thought if I could
you're out the right process I could
heal myself I could change my
relationship with writing it was really
painful to know I was getting paid a lot
of money and I was writing something but
it was never even close to my potential
like I knew I was so much better than I
was then I was limiting myself to be so
I was always looking for a better
process and and it never helped me I
couldn't overcome my demons but I I have
an encyclopedic I just I didn't have an
encyclopedic knowledge of writer
processes so when I worked with writers
I think especially because I I fought so
hard against my demons and I never
actually overcame them I think I'm
really attuned to people fight with
their demons and so when I first started
teaching to be perfectly honest I taught
to get out of the house I talked those
lonely as a writer I talk because it was
fun I talk because I wanted to be a
stand-up so at least I it was sort of a
way of performing but the real reason I
was teaching is I wanted to help people
evolve their process heal their process
a lot of people I want to teach people I
want to teach people how they could
become reach their full potential
because I figured if I could do that for
someone else that I would know how to do
it for myself and what I found is I'm
really good at doing it for other people
and I can't do it for myself so so yes
to rap back to your question I think
there are people who just know nothing
but success they're really smart I think
they can give really good feedback on a
script I think they're really smart and
they can really be beneficial but often
in terms of process they don't even know
they're doing things about knowing
they're doing it and they can't always
empathize or connect with people who are
struggling in certain ways so yeah I
think the fact that in some ways you
know I did a 19-4 hire studio projects I
worked with great people I got really
close on some projects I made good money
in some ways I was very successful in
terms of credits and Battlefield Earth
and and enjoying writing and feeling
like I was writing the best of my
I was a failure so I feel like I was
both successful and it fell to depend on
how you want to look at it and I do
think that really helps me as a teacher
because I can work with someone who's
brand-new who's really struggling as we
know why they're struggling and I work
right now with a lot of show runners who
are so amazing
but they just want to get that much
better so I can I can use all of all of
that collective experience and I think
that I in a lot of ways I think my
writing career was there to launch my
teaching career I just didn't know it at
the time it is yeah
you